ccsd leaders just wrapping up a press
conference following that brutal attack
they're discussing ways to keep this
from happening again victoria saha joins
us live with what students and staff can
expect after they return from spring
break victoria
superintendent dr jesus jarrah was here
today along with other members of law
enforcement to discuss that attack on
the teacher they say enough is enough
and now is the time to take proactive
measures
school violence within ccsd has been an
issue for a very long time but school
administrators say thursday's attack on
an el dorado high school teacher was the
last straw we have heard from them
continuously say violence on campus with
students attacking each other or staff
members will not be tolerated but today
we're learning any student accused of
these acts will be recommended for
expulsion and those students will be
prosecuted to make sure the community
stays safe
we are instituting the following
principles
when they come back on monday
will be directed to facilitate and
address the entire student body
and reminding them of the student code
of conduct
that they will be held accountable to
if students violate the student code of
conduct it will be clear what the
consequences will be
dr jarrah also says all staff members
will now be able to have a panic button
on them that would allow them to contact
first responders immediately they are
still working out the logistics but say
el dorado high school is the first to
get these i did get a chance to speak
with the president of the clark county
education association she says that she
did get a chance to speak with that
teacher who was attacked and she says
there were never any threats made
against her and this student in fact was
one of her higher achieving students
victoria zaha live local now